we have a voicemail number
that number is 2192 David P you know
I've said it many times before
criticize me for things I said if you
don't like them if I got it wrong
but don't criticize me for things I
haven't talked about here is a caller
who is furious with what I said about
manosphere Darling Andrew Tate
except I don't know what this guy's
talking about I didn't never say any of
this stuff listen to this
what does that even mean no
no for for coming to the conclusion that
Andrew James automatically guilty after
being arrested I find it funny that you
guys had never talked about everything
one thing pretty much at all and then
all of a sudden when he gets arrested
you guys you guys make videos about him
what
and now he's been let go after four
months
it's crazy to think that once upon a
time the Liberals were born were against
the government and all of their
Shenanigans and now it's the Trump
supporters and now you guys are for
government everything you guys are not
questioning questioning anything
government related dude I don't know
what the hell you're talking about so I
Milo Kuklinski I don't know what that's
about
as far as I'm concerned uh there are two
claims made about me one that when
Andrew Tate was arrested I said he's
pretty much guilty and two that I had
never spoken about Andrew Tate prior to
that both statements are false first and
foremost I've spoken about Andrew Tate
in a segment about the manosphere in
which I talked also about uh liver King
and Jordan Peterson so I have spoken
about Andrew Tate once before
secondly I haven't weighed in at all
about the Andrew Tate arrest and in fact
during a live stream someone said David
what do you think about Andrew taint
being arrested and I said I don't think
anything I don't have anything to say
it's just it's not really a topic on
this show I don't know he's accused of
crimes I don't know I just I just have
no idea so listen I'm glad to defend the
things I've said on this show
and I'm glad to correct things I've said
on this show if they are wrong
but don't call me about things I haven't
said call someone who's actually said it
but you're wasting everybody's time we
have a fantastic bonus show for you
today
Florida has expanded its don't say gay
rules to include up to and including
12th grade
and this is part of why Republican Mega
donors are not happy with Rhonda Sanctus
we'll talk about it on the bonus show
secondly there are more calls for
schools to drop Native American mascots
and some schools could end up losing
State money over this very interesting
what's going on and lastly we now have
two shootings that have taken place
stemming from a mistaken address and
this is putting the spotlight back on
stand your ground laws the way we really
haven't seen since stand your ground
laws were at the heart of the George
Zimmerman Trayvon Martin killing years
and years ago so we're going to talk
about stand your ground when producer
Pat joins me on the bonus show oh the
bonus show where you want to make money
sir everybody else that makes money to
fund themselves is bad that's exactly
right we're going to be making some
money on the bonus show you can sign up
at joinpakman.com you can get instant
access to the bonus show the commercial
free audio and video streams of the show
the members only soundboard Obama as
well as getting invited to the
member-only town halls the next of which
will be announced very soon sign up at
joinpakman.com use the coupon code
indicted or indicated both work both get
you a discount I'll see you then